wasn't that the guy that burnt down the
place oh he's probably pissed that I
stopped him Oh
oh my oh oh why well thanks so much for
that have a nice day - you too
Jesus has just started this part you
can't jump out at me like that okay what
do we got here
what is that balling a bowl full of
fingers there's one of those mind I've
said it before but [ __ ] this place I've
still got those fingers left ha ah these
fingers alright anyway alright see I
don't know where we're going here kind
of just wandering is there a battery in
here what's the point of this place okay
alright anyway man this guy is gonna
have some story when he gets out of all
this giant with a teddy bear obsession a
kitchen full of dangerous stuff deadly
diseases
lots of cannibalism going on here father
Martin why couldn't I have just thrown a
chair through the window where you were
talking to me from and I joined you like
that why do I always have to because
this isn't exactly strong glass here I
would have bashed my way through that in
a heartbeat it supposed to go in deal
whose turn on to vouch put out the fire
and then we'll go me up which why you're
Martin Oh
wait a minute it's that it's that for
real Jeff for real is that for real
is that really like is that hang on to
file special research general problem
for the past several months mountain
Bluebird has been endeavoring to
ascertain by research study instruction
and some practice what value if any
could be derived from si sleep induction
and H hypnotic techniques when applied
to war in specific agency problems can't
we create by postage control and action
contrary to an individual's basic moral
principles can we guarantee total
amnesia under any and all conditions can
we alter a person's personality how long
will it hold what are the full details
on a sleep inducing machine I don't know
but is this is this for real here is
this for real is that really the exit am
I really getting out of here hello
you're dead congratulations you won the
not living award look for father Martin
where is he I can't even my night-vision
isn't picking very much up whoa what is
that what is that what is that is that
some sort of Searchlight looking for me
okay my night vision is not going very
far because I'm almost out of batteries
plot those out with these here okay all
right I'm just gonna try to follow the
path to some source of light this seems
to be the closest one let's go there
I have a feeling that I'm not gonna get
out of this this easily the store needs
a key well screw this door what was that
without a good good good ghost without a
ghost Teague what the hell man is that
project walrider okay I heard something
skittering along the ground whoa this is
so cool
oh that's a dead body okay this is so
cool and it's so creepy oh my god you
guys hear that is is this whistling
through the trees or what
okay well that lamp does not help very
much thank you very much
ha how alive are you whoa I'm missing
two fingers but I think pretty good I
don't even know your name but I've come
to think of you it's one of my blood my
Paul I hope you don't mind and I hope
you don't indulge the vanity of
self-pity the fear that your suffering
is more than others we all must endure
this and you are nearly done
there's no way to heaven but by the
cross and every man needs another to
help drive the nails in I am here for
you I am waiting ahead I am the shadow
in the night hi
I'm Batman oh I have the power okay
okay why are there so many bugs around
that lamp in the rain I don't know well
there seems to be some lock gates over
here I don't know what I'm supposed to
do and how how is so much blood going
everywhere there is an exorbitant amount
of blood in every location that I've
gone to in this entire compound oh damn
it
everything's locked up
I heard that everything's locked up how
am I supposed to get anywhere I don't
have a key
ambassador the window come on I'm gonna
run out of every of my batteries if I
keep this up it was where was that
searchlight that was like spinning
around
where was it it's over here okay I need
to swap out again what is this aha BAM
[ __ ] get down go aw damn what's up
battery ki dokie Loki active what yeah I
got the key
I didn't even see the key all this up
I'm mister ghosty how're you doing I'm
assuming you're not gonna actually hurt
me that's just an assumption I'm gonna
have to make at this point I hear ya I
hear you mr. ghosty goo how much you
leave me there for though quickly click
Lang a ride sweet
that'll keep the ghost out this nice
wire friends ghost can't make it through
that what am i what I saw something up
there can't tell me I didn't I've
learned that every time I see something
out of the corner of my eye it was
actually uh something oh don't tell me
it wasn't
oh come on radio usually their batteries
buy these radios okay whatever I'm doing
fine but it is rather dark so it might
be a problem
Oh under the door crawl under it was a
ghost
pretty go what did it boss
what did it crawl back regions in the
beer Oh No thank you
oh god help me I think I've seen the
wall writer sorry Nathan Murdoch the
wall rider is apparently a ghost and
that's the long and the short of it
plain and simple it's a ghost okay is
there anything else I need from over
here do I go right up this ladder here
I'm gonna go right up the ladder cuz I'm
running out of battery just think I got
the plane to go Lupe my way oh that's
actually like I got I said before then
the graphics of this game are really
good but I mean it works so well for the
atmosphere of this game it's so well
done
all right I haven't jumped what how long
have you been up there hey I'll take
kindly your bull give me that I'm taking
this how long have you been up there
[ __ ] mother humper all right wait why
did I come up here Oh to get down here
okay so if I oh hello
I would have just jumped and died okay
so if I get down there I can jump over
and then I can there's a ladder down but
let's see what's over here there's a
whole bunch of walkways can I crawl on
this ledge yes I can i how do I know
where I'm going father Martin you're
such an a-hole why in the world did you
run away from me okay am I supposed to
be able to make this jump I hope so here
we go up yep there we go that was easy
don't know why I was worried okay I see
some boxes there there we go bump and
climb up here it's a lot of climbing
going on - can't see crawl up here there
we go
don't know where the hell I was supposed
to be but I'm up here I'm up here now
that's all that matters right it's all
that matters
hello who said that who said that
oh hi I'll get out how did how do I do
that
how do I do that how do I do it
how do I do that come at me bro walrider
I could see his ghost - I know friend
you're not looking so good looks like
your brains a little exposed there and
you got something on your arm well I'll
just not point out all his flaws and
carry on my way is that the guy is that
the guy from before no that's this guy
this traitor you're not the same guy
you're not him don't try to pretend like
you're him you're not him why is the
music changing yeah yeah battery I'll
get to in a second
Oh seriously how many freakin people
were in this asylum place how many
honestly there's way too many bodies
here wait what are you doing Oh what are
you doing Oh what are you doing what are
you doing over there
Oh what are you doing what are you doing
stop that oh it's so weird what are you
doing I don't know what you're doing
whatever you doing whatever you do and
just stop that oh you're not doing
anything you're you have a straitjacket
on never mind I thought you were doing
something never mind
well drawn to hit the old dusty trail
okay where am I supposed to go all right
tell me your secrets where am I supposed
to go here nope
okay not there maybe I was maybe I was
just maybe it was so window I can climb
in doesn't look like it what am I
supposed to do here hey hey excuse me
officer I need some guidance I seem to
be a bit lost oh here we go okay right
here that was hard to see man how this
is navigating a maze awful in the dark I
can't see anything I just gotta follow
the light what what ah he didn't see me
thankfully somehow did he see me well
how did the big guy get out of here
there's my teddy bear out here
no one better be mocking me I know when
someone's making fun of me I know okay
he can't get me up here right I'm
climbing up way away from him just
follow the ledge he's just out for an
evening stroll probably just out to cry
his emotions out in the night because no
one could see your tears in the rain
I should stop making fun of him cuz he
will rip my head off at some point he's
already done it before okay alright I
think I see a way down here let's go how
do I go ahh that was not what I intended
to do there was a nice little landing
zone there you could have went and never
mind whatever you're just a giant idiot
okay let's wait till my bones mend all
over again
oh sorry my legs only went inside my
[ __ ] for a little bit there but I
pulled them out and we're all good to go
damn it
this date they made me stock up on
batteries for this one section I know it
okay got a hurry through here before I
actually do run out I knew
oh no oh no no no okay haha I looked
around now whatever you were stopping me
from going to looking in a word by now
what now lose a little piggy okay so if
I read that correctly that means that I
now am going towards the female ward
which I wasn't going towards before ergo
I don't know what that means but
apparently there's now gonna be female
psycho crazy bunker ladies yay okay I
got to go this way towards the fountain
of blood once again what what what I saw
something something
yeah okay once again way too much blood
and way too many dead bodies this is
disgusting oh nasty
okay there's a little bit of light here
I wish it would help me illuminate the
rest of my way
I don't even know which way I'm supposed
to go here I'm surprised my camera's
still working in the middle of the night
it's out of our yes thank you I need
that so badly I think it might be
randomized as to cuz there are cameras
and radios and stuff lying around but it
might be randomized as to what actually
has a battery that you can use maybe
based on needs so if I am actually like
running out of batteries they'll be more
around I've only got three left so let's
try to make them last by getting totally
lost in not knowing where I'm going
that's great idea yeah good job
markiplier you're the best gamer ever
this is why so many people watch you
like favourites of ramen do you think
barn bar than no never it's gotta be oh
those bars were open I thought maybe
these boxes were stacked there for a
reason okay so I'm inside the mood has
changed actually it went from yellow to
gray and cool colors warm colors to cool
colors Lisa I'm out of the woods
but I have a bad feeling about this
place maybe no not yet
no not yet you know I'm following you
you could you know stay with me as I
follow you that would be incredibly
helpful and looked like he had lace like
straps on his back so I think he
reconfigured a straitjacket into sort of
priests clothing some sort either way
he's psycho
but he'll going into this place and not
leaving immediately was crazy okay whoa
is that nothing we're you kidding me
that was nothing you know one I got a
bug floating around my head well that
was nothing are you kidding me screw you
screw you a ho
stop hanging around of noises I don't
appreciate it very much
bringing out a batteries they need to
keep moving I keep stopping like to
listen and smell the roses
hi how's it going man that guy does not
let up that guy does not leave me alone
wonder what ever happened to the two
naked guys I miss those guys those guys
were nice a bit more polite - what have
we got here what going on ah another
battery thank you so much I need these
I need these so badly okay anyway
I think that's enough for that part we
got out of the woods so now is a good
enough stopping point we're going into
the female Ward's we're not done with
this yet so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you stop racing around and the
next video
[Music]
Oh
me me
so I did that scare me I have no idea
I just saw a big shadowy figure I saw a
shadow